you know i look at all this [ __ ] not
[ __ ] sorry but you produced all those i
call it [ __ ] you do yeah sure good for
you it's your [ __ ] man yeah you produced
cable guy anchor mentality at night
super bad pineapple express for getting
sarah marshall get him to the greek
bridesmaids the big city and first of
all i think you know you're 54 years old
you're five years older than me and i
feel like a complete [ __ ] failure i
love all the [ __ ] you've done but i look
20 years older than you no you don't if
you shave you have gray hair that's it
that's the only [ __ ] difference but
one thing you know people talk about is
freaks and geeks and just briefly you
know i've read inter interviews where
you talk about
i knew it was gonna get canceled i knew
every week was that is that true did you
really feel like from the get-go oh yeah
this is gonna get cancelled and why what
was the studio's complaints why did you
feel that this wasn't going to make it
well we made it at a time when there was
no head of nbc
so
the head of programming left and
suddenly there was a more business
oriented guy who was above him who got
to make all the decisions and because he
wasn't some programming guy who felt the
need to ruin your process
he just loved the script and we said hey
we want these people in it and he went
great
usually as you know the the network
will
screw with your casting choices because
it's the only place that they really can
mess with your show so when you go i'd
like this person to be the lead they're
like bring me four choices
yes which is the dumbest part of all of
television is this moment where you
debate the network so if you create a
show
and you say i want this person as the
lead
if you lose that fight you've already
ruined your show your show is done you
you might as well not shoot it
it's it's all about that
and
so we've had good and bad experiences
with that but in this experience he just
greenlit everything
we shoot the pilot
uh shake kazdan came in to direct it we
had bill pope as the cinematographer who
did like the matrix yeah the greats of
all time and paul feig was just so tuned
into what he wanted to do with that type
of show
and
then they hired a head
of programming
and very quickly someone just said he
doesn't like it
just didn't get it he doesn't get it
they said he went to private school he
he's not feeling it and so
from the very beginning we knew we were
in trouble and
you know you can see it in the time slot
and the marketing and
the fact that we would be on for a week
and off for two weeks and back for two
weeks and offer three weeks
so there was no rhythm to create a
relationship with the audience
and we felt like our days were numbered
and then he took me out to lunch and he
said can your characters have more
victories
because it was a melancholy show about
getting your ass kicked and and the
solids you take from your family and
your friends when you're really having a
hard time
and you say no that's not what this
show's about
yet i had to and i was young enough to
not know
that
that it's bad to be honest
i didn't really know how to work those
relationships yeah yeah yeah and so the
thing that i did to give him a victory
was there was an episode where bill is
in gym class
and there's a high pop that comes up to
him
and he catches it and he goes crazy
celebrating
and then he doesn't realize that it's
not the final out and everyone is
scoring and tagging up
that was as close as a victory right uh
and
so
it did turbocharge the show because
you know when you think you might get
canceled at any second
you know you use all your good ideas
nothing saved for season two and three
right and so it became a bit compressed
yeah and you shot the finale we shot the
finale like three episodes before the
end of the season which is crazy we
didn't want it to end abruptly on
nothing unsettled right and so
i remember paul and i were in las vegas
it's hilarious i flew to vegas to see
rodney dangerfield with adam
and by the way that's my favorite
comedian of all time yeah he so he he's
the one that we we you know we loved i
had seen him as a kid and we got to hang
out with him it was a magic night but i
bumped into feig who happened to also be
in vegas and we were just talking about
it and we i was like man let's just do
the final episode
he hadn't directed i i felt i felt bad
but he was the best writer on the show
it was such a vision for him i didn't
think that he could
keep up with the writing if he was
directing and so i i hadn't let him
direct
because i just felt that that was so
important right and so i said just write
and direct the last episode
and then we'll shoot it in the middle of
the season so if we get canceled we'll
have a finale
and in our conversations in vegas we
were like what happened to lindsay
and we thought i think she'd become a
deadhead like that seems to be the
middle between the burnouts
and the athletes would be the deadhead
and then paul wrote and directed the
most incredible finale it's it's really
remarkable then i felt guilty that he
hadn't directed more episodes but i
think the reason why the whole show is
good is because
uh he had